ida c'est un peu un mythe et puis moi la
première dans l'intimité temps en temps
on se dit qu'on n'est pas concerné alors
qu'on fait si moi je me sens pas pour je
me sors je m'affole pas quoi le sida
qu'est ce que vous en pensez pas en
parler ou pas ah ouais ouais on parlait
ouais ouais faut en parler mais moi je
me sens pas trop je me sens je m'affole
pas le sida qu'est ce que vous en pensez
il faut en parler ou pas oui il faut en
parler pour lever le tabou je pense que
je connais pas plein de choses sur le
sida et je pense avoir plein de choses à
apprendre encore c'est bien d'en parler
mais je trouve qu'on en parle tous je ne
sais pas vraiment ce que c'est comme
maladie mais je sais que ça me touche
beaucoup de gens et que c'est fatal le
sida ça vous concerne
bah oui quand tout le monde le sida ça
vous concerne
je pense qu'on est tous concernés à
partir du moment
si c'est possible d'être touchés et
j'ai eu un cas dans ma famille et du
coup je sais à quel point ça peut être
dur ou porter des préservatifs
non pas du tout c'est un point de vue je
suis totalement opposé à ce pour porter
des préservatifs
bien sûr s'il faut oui j'en porte oui ça
m'est jamais arrivé encore et pourquoi
j'aurais aussi d'une bonne prévention
contre le sida
oui mais c'est peut-être l'habitude
pourquoi pour éviter notamment
d'attraper cette maladie les autres
gestes et mst pour éviter tout souci de
grossesse vous porter des préservatifs
voilà non l'amour elle doit pas y avoir
de des barrières entre la chair la chair
et les six gars c'est pas une barrière
et 6 mai avec la prévention on se
retenant un peu puis en essayant de
savoir d d'avoir des connaissances
sexuelle sur sa partenaire on peut très
bien préservé mais sans utiliser la
capote
[Musique]